well the raiders back home for the first
time in three weeks this sunday their
showdown with the colts could have some
serious playoff implications john treach
has more from the weekly wednesday press
conference
john gruden considers himself a pilot of
this silver and black playoff pursuing
plane which makes the irony of the whole
season nearly careening off the runway
against the new york jets
even more rich but through triumph and
turbulence the raiders are right where
they want to be
7-5 yeah the raiders nearly had to
deploy their flotation device
to get out of east rutherford new jersey
last sunday either way fans were
utilizing that white paper
hyperventilating bag as the jets
had the lead with 13 seconds left in the
game
it's the kind of stress no one needs yet
everyone expects
with a month left in the season the good
news the raiders can win their way into
just
their second playoff trip in 18 years
it's going to be challenging but nothing
is more difficult than their flight path
to this point
after 12 ball games seven of them have
been on the road
a lot of them have been across country
during a pandemic it's been a challenge
we've had a lot of injuries
so we paid the price to get here and uh
we'll see
we'll see who helps us land the plane we
need some of these
passengers to jump on you know we got
good football teams coming in here that
have the same aspirations
that we do and we know we got to play
better and we know we're going to get
everybody's best shot
yeah injury updates are the talk of the
times running back josh jacobs
did not practice either to defensive
backs jeff heath and david arnett the
colts are a three-point favorite even
though the game
is in las vegas brian